okay well
these are notorious danger sign in the
book when you see one of these you know
materials get a little bit more tricky
it's certainly mathematically more
tricky
and smoothing splines are a little bit
more challenging mathematically but
they're beautiful as well so
let's talk about them
um
the takeaway message of a smoothing
spline is the way of filling splines
without having to worry about knots
okay but it approaches a problem from a
completely different point of view
what we have
is we have this Criterion that we fit to
the data
so on the left here is the residual sum
of squares
and so this part of it tries to make the
function G the argument of this
Criterion is a function an unknown
function G of x
and this tries to make G as close to
what the observed y's is possible at
each of the observed X I's okay
and we search in over all functions
now if we didn't have the second term we
just pick any crazy interpolating
function that that visited every y
exactly
so what the second term does is it
constrains the functions that over which
we search to be smooth
this is a somewhat complex penalty here
but what it is is that the second
derivative of the of the function
squared
integrated over the whole domain
second derivatives are going to pick up
Wiggles of the function I'm going to
pick up departures for example from
linearity
and if you square it it gets rid of the
sign and integrate means add them up so
it adds up all non-linearities in the
function
and this Lambda is called the roughness
penalty and it's it's it modulates the
how much of this penalty you're imposing
okay
and so we call it a tuning parameter and
Lambda is bigger than equal to zero
so the smaller Lambda the more Wiggly
the function can be means you're not
putting that much much weight on this
penalty
and eventually if Lambda 0 we'll get
that interpolating function because we
won't pay any price for bean Wiggly and
so we may as well go through all the
data
on the other hand
as Lambda gets really large if it gets
off to Infinity so we want this you know
we pay a big price for any
contribution from this term the function
will eventually be forced to be linear
because the function that's linear has
second derivative zero and so this term
would be zero only if Lambda gets to
Infinity we'd have to make this zero to
not be overwhelmed by this penalty which
means that the function's got to be
linear so this would be a linear model
so that's that's a really uh pretty way
of of of setting up a smoothing problem
which gives us a whole range of of
values as Lambda goes from zero to
Infinity we get a range of functions
that solutions that are going to go from
a linear function to a very Wiggly
function that goes through the data
we call the solution to that problem a
smoothing spline
and
and it turns out
and the reason it's called a smoothing
spline is that the solution is a spline
but it's a weird spline it's got a knot
at every single unique value of the X's
which sounds ridiculous when you first
hear about it but that's what it is
but it turns out that
it's not as as crazy a function as you
like because the roughness penalty
controls how Wiggly the function can be
and it's pretty amazing that this has a
solution at all right it has a nice
Simple Solution exactly and I guess a
clue as to why it's a cubic spine is
that the second derivative is in the
function yeah right and there's actually
a whole family of splines whereas if the
if you have like about a third houses
wherever if there's a if it's a kth
derivative then it's this 2K plus first
yeah that's right there's a whole
hierarchy of families of these guys and
it's crazy I mean if if I'd ever hadn't
heard of this and you showed me this
problem and said I want to solve this
problem I'd say forget about it go and
visit the math department well actually
it was sold in the math department but
we're very glad they did that because
it's a very elegant and the proof isn't
too hard right for those who are
mathematically inclined in our first our
our our big data mining book the um
let's just go learn we have in an
exercise we have the sketch of that
proof right so if you like these kind of
mathematical things it's a it's a fun
proof to go through yeah and it might
show up in one of the quizzes
okay a few details
as I said they smoothing splines avoid
the knot selection issues and and we
have a single Lambda that needs to be
chosen that's quite attractive
rather than having to pick a whole bunch
of different knots
the details are a little
um too complex to describe you but
fortunately we got a function in R
called Smooth dot spline and it'll fit
the smoothing spine for you and it takes
some arguments and you know and it's
it's very easy to use
um
it turns out that when when you fit a
smoothing spline if you if you take the
fitted values at each of the of the
observed x's and put those into a vector
which we call G hat of of index by
Lambda
you can write G hat Lambda as a matrix
times y we Y is the observed Vector of
of responses and S this of course is
going to be an N by n Matrix
and this is is determined by the
positions of the x's and and the
particular value of Lambda that we
you've used
now this is a special form we call this
a linear smooth because it's a linear
operator linear operator times y
linear regression of course is also a
linear operator so is polynomial
regression and all the methods we've
talked to talked about up till now the
the cubic splines all of them result in
expressions like this but this one does
as well that's somewhat important it
means that there's it's got mathematical
properties that are attractive
attractive
and one of them is is that we can
compute something called the effective
degrees of freedom
so you know we've got knots at every
observed data point here and so
potentially it sounds like
using our previous calculations that
there could be as many as n Plus or n
degrees of freedom it's a natural cubic
spline
but the degrees of freedom are much less
because of the the roughness penalty and
it turns out that the S the natural
estimate for the degrees of freedom is
the sum of the diagonal elements of this
Matrix and that's the expression we've
got over here and we call those the
effective degrees of freedom
so now when we use a smoothing spline we
can actually specify Lambda by instead
specifying the effective degrees of
freedom and a little bit reverse of
reverse engineerings done in the
function to figure out what is the
Lambda that would result in
such a a degrees of freedom right and so
it can figure it out and so in R it's as
simple as that you can say I want to
smooth dot spline of age and wage wage
is a response with degrees of freedom
equals 10. so I made a way to think
about it's like a polynomial of degree
10 but it's it has about that complexity
but it's it's smoother so the degrees of
freedom are not all spent on 10
polynomial terms rather spread out over
the whole spectrum of of the function
from rough from smooth to rough yeah
very very attractive way of fitting
nonlinear functions
if if you don't want just fix the
degrees of freedom you can actually
estimate the smoothing parameter by
cross-validation
so leave one out cross-validation is
quite attractive for smoothing splines
because there's a really nice expression
similar to what we got in in linear
regression
for the cross-validated sum of squares
so here's the expression this is the sum
of cross-validated residuals this
complicated looking thing here is the
fitted smoothing spline if we leave out
the ith data pair
and evaluated at the point x i right so
that's a cross-validated fit
and to compute this whole expression
over the sum of that we'd have to leave
out each point and refit the function
each time
well it turns out you can just fit a
smoothing spline to the original data
and divide each of the residuals by 1
minus the corresponding diagonal element
of that that smoother Matrix right so
nice so like a magic formula it computes
a cross-validated leave on our
cross-validated residual sum of squares
and so you do this for a range of values
of Lambda and pick the value that that
minimizes it
so that's done automatically in the
function smooth dot spline if you don't
specify Lambda or the degrees of freedom
it'll just automatically use this cross
validation so it's it's it's very
attractive
okay so here's a
um
an example these two functions look
almost the same one is using 16 degrees
of freedom of fixed degrees of freedom
for the smoothing spline
and the other ended up picking it used
leave one at Cross validation and ended
up picking 6.8 degrees of freedom
so that probably raises some eyebrows
how can we have 0.8 degrees or three 6.8
well the effective degrees of freedom
formula doesn't guarantee you an integer
and so you can have effective degrees of
freedom in you know non-integer values